a quanto pare vinto il premio come
migliori youtuber alla festa della rete
che dire grazie mille a tutti quelli che
mi hanno votato io avrei fatto vincere
qualcun altro ma comunque è stato
talmente inaspettato che non sono manco
andato ritirando il premio è forse da
una parte e stato un bene visto che uno
dei due conduttori era diana del bufalo
ed essere premiato da lei sarebbe stato
abbastanza quindi per festeggiare ho
voluto sapere da voi che cos'è youtube
italia in quattro parole in pieno stile
gex film e non solo per questo video
copieremo il suo format perché siamo
youtuber italiani ea quanto pare
facciamo solo quello questi sono state
le vostre migliori risposte in youtube
italia in quattro parole un deathmatch a
squadre kattegat i gatti gatti leggere
le descrizioni stanca cazzo conto è vero
saba cool e adam kadmon mors tua vita
mea fare soldi senza lavorare davvero
esiste youtube italia gli es
è una cagata pazzesca pizza mandolino
mafia banana merda che caga merda
cestino dei rifiuti pieno o perché siamo
tutti spazzatura bella pianti pianti
pianti pianti ma dove sono finito guardo
video fine ciao comprate il mio libro
cazzo se siete stronzi primo io topi fa
jan koller bel video iscritto ricambi la
fortuna di google infinita dispensa di
autismo coperta corta piedi scoperti la
possibilità di creare e guerra e pace
io però non so di cosa tratti guerre
pari a terapia capisco come antani
cadavere ambulante senza innovazione
sembra non avere senso ma c'e la scena
una prostata troppo infiammata un casino
bello però tutto tranne che bello a
grazie mike of the desert non è una
community
la nuova televisione credo tutti
gameplay di minecraft intrattenimento
allo stato puro challenge bel a me ne
bastano due giancarlo magalli la copia
dell'americano e questo video ne è una
prova
copia inception una grandissima
opportunità mancata tanto ma tanto
disagio
concordo come il molise non esiste
avranno ancora di moda le battute sul
molise mi sono perso un pomeriggio e
dulcis in fundo e se
3 solo tutta colpa di favi j è questo
video mi ha fatto scendere la
depressione perché io già sapevo che
sarebbero arrivate queste risposte ma le
volevo sentire di persona perché
purtroppo su internet funziona così
bellissimo video no dai
dimmelo sinceramente era una merda e tu
sei uno stronzo quindi ho voluto
chiedere in questo periodo così buona
sposo cosa ne pensasse la gente di
youtube italia è risultato è questo vado
a buttarmi dalla finestra
ci vediamo ad un prossimo video